[Music]
during the coronavirus pandemic many
have gone the extra mile to help others
healthcare workers scientists and
ordinary people
we look to peru where lots of children
have lost their parents to covet 19 and
need assistance
and to south africa where researchers
discovered the omicron variant
but first to india according to official
figures more than five and a half
million people work in the health care
sector there
most are women who feel they never get
the recognition they deserve so at the
start of this year they took to the
streets time and again
ushalodi wakes up early every morning
she helps her paralyzed mother eat
and change her clothes
and looks after the medical needs of her
father who's suffering from asthma
then she leaves for her job as a
community health worker
we monitor the health indicators of
pregnant women newborn babies children
under the age of six and adolescent
girls
we also help them with their basic
primary education
we ensure that children get nutrition
monitor their weight height and
vaccinations
her wage is barely enough to get by
my weight is close to 10 000 rupees
about 120 euros per month
it is meager and the payment often gets
delayed with the kind of inflation we've
been witnessing for the past few years
it's become extremely difficult to make
ends meet
we have to struggle even for basic
amenities like cooking gas cooking oil
medicines for sick parents and other
basic needs
how are we supposed to live
usha uses this app to maintain the
health vaccination and nutrition records
of the families she's responsible for in
her community
she's come here today to do a regular
medical checkup
after the day's work she joins others
like her who are campaigning for better
wages and working conditions
[Applause]
[Music]
we've been protesting for more than a
month now we need permanent regular work
contracts our salary should be increased
and we should get benefits like pension
and provided fund coverage
millions of these female health workers
have been the backbone of the country's
health care system
they've been on the front lines of
india's efforts to deal with the
coronavirus pandemic
one of the key issues that
you know concerns all the anganwadi
women across india is that they should
be regularized as permanent employees
their work should be recognized as work
and not as voluntary work
economists believe losing these health
workers will impact essential medical
services nationwide
contribute to not only the well-being of
those set of children but they
because they are laying the foundation
for adult life
they are contribute to adult
productivity future income growth uh the
entire economy really so the work that
they do is really crucial it's the basis
for building a just an equitable society
and the tasks that they do are also
quite tedious so not recognizing them as
workers and leaving this very important
task uh to what you call volunteers is
unfair to both the
beneficiaries of the program the
citizens who you're serving as well as
to the anarchy workers who are providing
these services
these workers are pivotal to india's
coveted vaccination programme
but will their demands be met
[Applause]
our mlas and mps should try and live
their life with 10 000 rupees or 120
euros per month
even during the peak of the covet
pandemic when most people were sitting
safely inside their homes
we did door-to-door checkups without
proper personal protective equipment and
health insurance
we will not give up until our demands
are met
from india to peru where families are
often large and close-knit
since the pandemic started extended
families have become more important than
ever as many children lost their parents
at least some have been lucky enough to
be taken in by relatives
[Music]
jose luis was once very talkative and
lively but that came to an end a year
and a half ago when his mother died from
covet 19.
he and his three brothers were abandoned
by his father
they're now under the care of their aunt
gabriela zarate
it's a huge responsibility for her to
take care of the four boys along with
five children of her own
my sister said i want all four of my
children to be with you i don't want
them to be separated
nine-year-old jose luis is one of around
100 000 children who have been orphaned
by covet 19 in peru
of the four brothers he was the one who
spent the most time with his mother and
he is the one most overcome with grief
[Music]
gabriella never expected to be caring
for nine children at the age of 30. life
in lima is hard and money is a constant
worry
she takes care of the children full time
and her husband provides the sole income
gabriela gets some money for each nephew
from the national family welfare program
in abif it helps but doesn't even begin
to cover the basic needs
currently inability only helps 18
thousand children orphaned bicovit-19 a
law approved in january will soon extend
that aid to another 25 000 orphans
this bill has been approved by the
peruvian congress and will allow us to
provide permanent economic assistance
for all children who are orphaned and
will apply to those who have lost
parents to other causes not just covet
19.
to earn more money the children collect
plastic bottles and with gabriella's
help they sell them to recycling
businesses
some days they go out together to search
for bottles activities like this help
them stay busy and get through the grief
innabe sends a psychologist every month
to evaluate the children it is the only
mental health care they receive
grief isn't something any child can
overcome if they only have therapy with
a psychologist once a month
they should be able to meet much more
often
the lack of resources and mental health
care affects peru's most vulnerable
children most of all
[Music]
it not only
[Music]
that are crucial to development
and if they can't overcome these huge
obstacles
it can lead to bigger problems later in
life
the pandemic has led to greater
inequality in peru making their
suffering even worse
every time we think the pandemic is
finally coming to an end a new variant
appears
that's what happened in late november
2021 when a team of researchers in south
africa discovered the omicron variant
the team was headed by brazilian-born
professor julio de oliveira one of the
world's leading genome sequencers
[Music]
this is the room where the omicron
variant of covet was first discovered
professor tullio de oliveira of
stellenbosch university in south africa
leads a team conducting the genomic
surveillance of deadly pathogens in a
100 million euro research facility
of course that a lot of the world got
very surprised how south africa can can
be a leader on genomic surveillance but
we we were not surprised because we we
have been leading on genomic
surveillance of other pathogens for the
past 20 years
it was this experience that set south
africa apart from the rest of the globe
scientific community in isolating
identifying and revealing omicron
south africa may be a middle-income
country dealing with rampant
unemployment stubborn poverty and one of
the highest rates of inequality in the
world
but its scientists are world leaders
leveraging the experience gained from
over three decades of managing one of
the globe's highest rates of hiv and
aids to be among the first to discover
the intricacies of covet 19 and its
variance
one thing that people don't realize is
that in addition to the omicron we also
detect that the the first variance was
the bit and was with our tip and
guidance that the united kingdom
identified the alpha so in reality we
have helped to identify three of the
five variants of concern
there was a hypothesis that a cluster of
neo-covet neo-covet-19 infections in
johannesburg south africa's economic
capital were behaving differently than
previous variants
he and his team worked around the clock
to make the omicron discovery with
hundreds of samples flown down to his
lab overnight in mid-november 2021
we did everything from beginning to the
end in 36 hours which which was a lot of
pressure
but but we we had a very clear line of
communications and that was reviewed by
all the top scientists in the world and
this was crucial because that's what
allowed not only the world
to understand that boosting against the
omicron would save lives and that's what
we did in south africa we had very small
number of deaths on the omicron wave and
we think that our very quick scientific
results helped the world to also have a
lower level of debt
but the discovery did not come without
its costs
south africa's economy took an immediate
hit as the government extended lockdown
measures in response to the announcement
while travel bans to and from the
country were immediately imposed by the
majority of the global community and the
team's lives were also immediately put
in danger
we
received many many many threats many
death threats at given time we had to
put like i'm security in the entrance of
the university because we could carry
our work and the big lesson to the world
is that they should make mechanisms that
don't penalize countries to identify
new pathogens otherwise we're going to
have more and more epidemics and
pandemics that that are not identified
early
the stress of omicron's discovery has
taken its toll
but professor oliveira believes that as
professional pressure increases so
should efforts to stay sane and healthy
both mentally and physically
so in order to relax in this kind of
environment yeah
you have to take almost every tool that
we have in the kind of mental health
basket
so in our lab we laugh a lot we we tell
jokes we play a lot yeah i do a lot of
exercise especially in nature long long
long hikes in the mountains go a lot to
the beach and also for me
meditation work well every morning i
wake up around 5am and do a session of
meditation before the day starts
after almost 30 years as a genome
sequencer professor de oliveira believes
the future of his profession lies in
computing
and that anybody who wants to follow in
his footsteps needs to be dedicated and
patient
the main advice to young people that
want to become a scientist or genomic
scientist yeah
is true is to invest a lot of time not
only on the
learning the lab techniques but learning
the coding computer coding yes software
development because these days
all the data that we produce in this lab
is completely automated
and after 27 years in south africa he
has no plans of moving abroad
even though he may have been thrown into
the global spotlight and his genomic
surveillance skills are in high demand
elsewhere
i always had a passion to work on
science that can help to save lives
and south african africa is a great
place from that and that's why we devote
a lot of our time
to
working with science but also inform
governments on how better to respond to
epidemics not only subscribe to covet
but also from other epidemics that that
cause millions of deaths
the coronavirus may have made professor
oliveira famous beyond the borders of
south africa but he remains committed to
his humble approach to solving some of
the world's most pressing health
problems
maybe you know some coronavirus deniers
in your country in a village in poland
some people are so afraid of
anti-vaxxers that they get their covet
jabs in secret
[Music]
barely 22 percent of the villagers are
vaccinated
the mayor and a local doctor feel
they're fighting a losing battle
[Music]
huge billboards greet visitors to
charney dunayats a village where
anti-vaccination sentiments run strong
the science say that covet vaccines are
genetic experiments on unsuspecting
citizens the organization that put them
up collects donations over social media
they won't talk to reporters the
campaign has found a following here
hardly anyone wears a mask
and most want nothing to do with covet
vaccines
they give all sorts of reasons
i haven't been vaccinated
[Music]
nearly 80 of people are unvaccinated the
authorities in the community of 16 000
seem unconcerned hardly anyone in the
town hall is wearing a mask and those
who are usually don't cover their mouth
and nose even though officially masks
and this public building are mandatory
mayor martin rothowski did launch a
vaccination drive
but that was quite a while ago
to be honest the
and that everyone should decide for
themselves if they want to get
vaccinated or not
yet the virus has also come to chinese
recently three people died of a tear
within just 10 days
at the health center dr theresa pazic
tries to convince her patients to get
vaccinated
with limited success
i feel tired of this pandemic and a bit
helpless
above all i think it's a lack of
education that's keeping people from
getting vaccinated
as a medical professional of course i
believe vaccines are the greatest
blessing of the 20th and 21st century
but most people here aren't interested
the health center administers only 20
vaccinations a month
matilda is the only one in her class who
is getting vaccinated right now
the other said they would get it during
the summer
even here the vaccination drive is
languishing
fewer and fewer people are interested
on the way back to chinese we see
another billboard with a simple message
don't get vaccinated
since the start of the pandemic dw's
derek williams has been intensively
following the latest coronavirus
research
and answering your questions
but this time viewer castilla vamarim
wants to ask derek something else
entirely
did you read all those books behind you
or is it just the green screen
the bookshelf behind me is not a green
screen it stands in my living room but i
know that some people are going to want
proof
so here it is
see
not faking it
to answer the question
no i haven't read all of the books
behind me just pretty much all of the
ones on the left in in english
the ones on the right in german belong
to my wife um i've only read a couple of
those
to be perfectly honest um i haven't read
as many books in the last couple of
years as i used to because i've spent
way too much time reading other stuff on
my computer most of it involving
some aspect of covet 19
everything i could get my hands on
that had to do with that day's topic
there were a lot of times when it was
really satisfying but i confess that
i've gotten
pretty tired of the whole pandemic thing
my producer wanted me to talk about what
it was like to report from home
more or less every day for two years
i'd love to say something profound but
i bet my story isn't really all that
much different
than millions of other people stuck
working from home except
i happen to appear on tv every day
i just did the best i could there were
some really
great days and then there were
some not so great ones winters
were hard
rituals helped
and
it felt like what i was doing
was meaningful
and i learned a lot it
felt like i spent a whole lot of time
and energy trying to convince people
to get vaccinated and
though people close to me have had the
rhona i haven't yet as far as i know so
that's something to look forward to
since i'm convinced now we're probably
all going to get it sooner or later
mostly though
like
pretty much all of us i'm ready to move
on i just don't know if the virus will
let me but that's what i hope
[Music]
even before the pandemic hit bangladesh
many parents married their daughters off
before their 18th birthdays
unicef says that mindset was gradually
changing until covet 19 reversed any
progress made the united nations
children's fund reports that 10 million
more child marriages could occur before
the end of the decade but we met a young
activist who's trying to change that
one day i asked my mother what her
favorite childhood memory was she said
when a girl marries at 13 she doesn't
have good childhood memories
what she said touched me if i'd married
that early i wouldn't have my friends i
wouldn't have been able to play and my
whole childhood would have been gone
the 17 year old now campaigns against
child marriages in
one bangladesh i saw some children
having a meeting for the platform child
they worked to stop child marriages and
torture against children
i filled out a form and signed up for
trainings on leadership and different
aspects of the campaign against child
marriages
i've been working with child forums
since i was 10.
from 2020 when the pandemic started to
september 2021 we stopped almost 700
child marriages
reba and her team for instance managed
to stop sumaya's marriage
she was not ready for marriage
however with the uncertainty about the
reopening of schools because of covert
her mother thought it was better to
marry her off since it was difficult to
cover her educational expenses
she also had other children to feed
i learned about it just two days before
the marriage at around 11
it was late to get the team moving but i
talked to all of them
the next morning with help from
officials and influential people in the
area
we convinced the family to stop the
marriage
marriage is a huge social problem in the
south asian country
the biggest challenge was threats from
local communities when i first started
working around 2014 15 i was quite small
how tall can a person be at the age of
10. i used to get calls with threats of
kidnapping they said my family would be
in danger and threatened me in different
ways
sometimes it wasn't even safe to stay at
home
according to local ngos 59 of women get
married before turning 18.
22 of them marry even before age 15.
studies revealed that during the covert
pandemic the number of child marriages
increased drastically
we hope that the children whose
marriages we stopped can continue their
education marriage is not a solution to
everything women can do a lot with their
lives if they want the parent
rayba
also raise awareness about the adverse
effects of child marriage
they're supported by the world vision
ngo
raba hopes the practice of child
marriage will end once and for all in
bangladesh
in this show we met many people who
dedicate their lives to helping others
maybe they'll inspire you to do the same
next time we'll be examining the
pandemic's impact on mental health until
then stay safe and well
[Music]
[Music]
you